[Applaudissements]
je sais pas comment c'est pour vous mais
en ce qui me concerne j'ai besoin de
faire un grand ménage de printemps de
temps en temps vous savez le grand
ménage qui déménage et en parlant de
déménagement j'ai déménagé six fois dans
ma vie d'adulte et les six fois je me
suis retrouvé avec des tas de trucs à
jeter à donner ou à recycler et à chaque
fois je me demande comment est ce que je
peut accumuler autant de choses c'est
vrai je suis pas une acheteuse
compulsive loin de là je suis même ultra
raisonnable mais malgré ça je trouve
toujours des choses dont je pourrais me
débarrasser
au moment de me mettre j'ai toujours une
certaine appréhension
c'est toujours un peu compliqué
d'imaginer ces doses de trucs à trier
arrangé et à chaque fois je me dis
peut-être que je devrai renoncer et tout
planqué tout enfermé dans un placard un
placard spécial truc dont je ne sais pas
quoi faire c'est vrai si je ferme bien
la porte
sauf qu'au fond de moi je serai que tout
est toujours là visibles ou pas et puis
si jamais un jour quelqu'un arrive et
ouvre la porte bounce tout va
dégringoler d'un coup va tous prendre
dans la figure et moi je vais regretter
de parement d'être occupés avant
c'est un peu comme avec nos émotions
des fois on garde tout à l'intérieur
bien enfermé dans un placard et puis un
jour quelqu'un ongles à porter la parole
ça peut faire mal
et je vais d'ailleurs vous parlez de
chiara carella neuf ans quand on s'est
rencontrés la première fois elle m'a
expliqué combien c'était difficile pour
elle de se retenir de se mettre en
colère son placard intérieur des bords
des ailes avaient beaucoup de peur
beaucoup d'angoissé et puis à l'école il
y avait toujours quelqu'un pour ouvrir
son placard et la cris pleurs
les gens autour d'elle n'arrivais pas à
comprendre et elle non plus d'ailleurs
je vais donc parler de mon ménage de
printemps
pour m'y mettre je me relie au bien-être
que ça me procure d'être dans une maison
propre rangé mais surtout débarrasser du
superflu de ce qui ne convient plus de
ce qu'ils me dessert je trie je range
que je dois garder et je dis au revoir à
ce qu'il me sers plus
pour commencer j'observe pendant un long
moment
je sors tout des placards et je me
remémore les souvenirs liés à ces objets
je peux ressentir de la tendresse de la
joie une certaine euphorie peut-être
mais aussi des sentiments moins agréable
un vague à l'âme à un moment de solitude
de la colère peut être
sans nous en rendre compte nous
accumulons beaucoup de déchet émotionnel
c'est déchets émotionnel pollue au
quotidien notre bien-être sans que nous
en soyons forcément conscient
ça me rappelle d'ailleurs cette fois où
j'ai retrouvé un sac que j'avais planqué
au fin fond d'un placard
qu'est ce qu'on peut en planque et des
trucs au fond des placards
c'est une copine qui me l'avait offert
et franchement en le voyant j'ai eu un
léger mouvement de recul parce que ce
sac
qu'est-ce qu'il était moche est tout
petit tellement risqué que je sais même
pas ce que j'aurais pu mettre dedans je
suis certaine que vous l'auriez trouver
moche ou aussi mais le pire c'est que
quand elle me l'a offert ma copine elle
m'a dit j'ai tout de suite pensé à toi
en le voyant
petit moche
bon franchement sur le moment j'étais
vexé mais elle elle avait l'air
tellement heureuse que moi j'ai dit vrai
mais il est génial j'adore aller trop
beau merci
mais j'étais un peu vexé parce que ce
sac ça n'était pas moi elle aurait dû le
savoir
enfin bref me voilà donc aujourd'hui
avec ce sac dans les mains et se
souvenir inconfortable qui remonte à la
surface et je me sens un petit peu en
colère un petit peu hérité
mais au fond qu'est ce qui m'énerve
vraiment le sac lui n'y est pour rien
son seul défaut c'est d'être moche et
inutile selon moi selon ma vision des
choses
ma copine à elle le trouvais génial et
pour être honnête on certainement que
certains d'entre vous l'aurait trouvé
génial aussi j'aurais dû me réjouir
qu'elle m'offre quelque chose qu'elle
adore et qui compte autant pour elle
et d'un coup j'ai porté un autre regard
sur ce sac j'ai revu la lueur de fierté
de malice dans les yeux de ma copine
quand elle me l'a offert
ça m'a fait sourire il a en fait ce
cadeau avait déclenché un tourbillon
d'émotions mais je n'avais pas
identifier leurs messages
je me suis tout de suite senti tout de
suite mieux avant après avoir compris et
surtout ça m'a vraiment appris quelque
chose sur ma façon de fonctionner et sur
ce que j'avais à faire pour ne plus
revivre ça
avec kiara on s'est dit que toutes ces
choses qu'elle ressentait en permanence
et qui la mettait si mal à l'aise
c'était peut-être autant de sacs qu'elle
avait reçus mais qu'elle ne s'était pas
autorisée a refusé et qui l'avait
empêché de réagir en étant elle même
elle ne s'était pas senti à respecter
elle ne s'était pas sentie écoutée unis
comprise
faire le ménage dans nos émotions
alors d'abord faire le ménage dans nos
placards c'est ça qui nous permet aussi
de faire le ménage dans nos émotions
ça permet aussi un moment
d'introspection faire le point sur qui
on est sur ce que l'on veut en tant
qu'adulte poser des mots sur des
ressentis n'est pas toujours évident
surtout quand les choses sont enfouies
depuis un long moment alors quand on est
un enfant
c'est pour ça que le rangement et le
ménage au quotidien sont eux aussi
essentiel ça évite de se retrouver avec
toutes ces choses qui nous encombre et
qui finissent par peser de plus en plus
lourd sur notre moral sur notre mental
et le mieux est bien c'est de le
réserver un petit temps chaque jour
ranger ses chaussures au lieu de les
laisser traîner de rentrer dans l'entrée
quand on rentre à la maison mais de ses
vêtements dans le panier à linge sale au
lieu de les abandonner en boule au
milieu de sa chambre passer un coup de
balai sous la table pour retirer les
miettes à la maison j'accorde de
l'importance à ces genres de choses
notre chez nous c'est notre refuge un
endroit dans lequel on doit se sentir en
sécurité
un endroit ressource qui doit être une
véritable contribution pour notre
bien-être
en feng shui il est question de laisser
circuler l'énergie pour vivre dans un
lieu harmonieux qui favorise la joie et
l'abondance mais pour circuler l'énergie
elle a besoin d'ordre et des espaces
alors nous on a un petit rituel chaque
soir on accorde 10 minutes pour ranger
des choses et en faisant que cela chaque
soir on range notre intérieur
s'occuper de notre maison physique va
nous aider à clarifier notre intérieur
si on y met de la conscience ce qui se
voit à l'extérieur est le reflet de ce
qui se passe dans notre intérieur
et je vous propose justement de partir à
l'intérieur de nous-mêmes
il existe un endroit là dans notre corps
tout près de notre coeur où vivent nos
émotions la vie dans la maison des
émotions est plutôt douce et agréable
c est une jolie maison lumineuse
éclatante
mais ça n'est pas une maison magique et
pour la garder dans cet état comme dans
toutes les maisons eh bien il faut
ranger et faire le ménage sinon ça
devient vite le bazar et ça crée des
tensions attention à l'intérieur de soi
mais aussi tensions avec les autres
d'autant que comme toutes les maisons
celle ci reçoit régulièrement des
visiteurs
à prendre a rangé sa maison des émotions
en prendre soin est une compétence
essentielle acquérir dès le plus jeune
âge pour être bien dans son corps bien
dans son coeur est bien dans sa tête
stéphanie couturier en parle très bien
dans son livre mon cours de relaxation
pour les enfants voilà ce qu'elle nous
dit cette petite maison logés en haut de
notre ventre accueille toutes les
émotions qui circulent dans notre corps
les joies les fierté l'amour mais aussi
la tristesse les colères ou les peurs
souvent ses émotions ne sont que de
passage elle s'arrête quelques instants
on ressent alors l'émotion et puis elles
repartent tranquillement mais parfois
elle s'installe
alors quand ce sont des émotions
agréable c'est facile mais quand c'est
de la peur de la colère ou de la
tristesse là ça se complique
c'est exactement comme quand on reçoit
du monde chez soi quelques personnes
joyeuse c'est facile à gérer on passe un
bon moment mais imaginez ces mêmes
personnes en colère on se sent alors
impuissants ont débordés submergés
et donc il faut les chasser et faire le
grand ménage après leur passage
kiara elle avait beaucoup de visiteurs
dans sa maison des émotions certains
étaient de passage mais beaucoup
s'étaient installés là depuis des années
alors on a fait le ménage
la sophrologie
comme toutes les pratiques
psychocorporelle
dispose d'un super chariot de ménage
elle alterne verbalisation du ressenti
et travail sur le corps
quelles émotions sont venus me rendre
visite aujourd'hui
comment je me suis senti en présence de
ses émotions
est ce que ces émotions ont laissé ma
maison propre et rangé ou est ce
qu'elles ont mis un peu de bazar
et puis est ce que ces émotions sont
toutes parties ou est ce que certaines
sont encore là
alors on regarde partout dans sa maison
des émotions où on ouvre les placards on
soulève les tapis on regarde derrière
les portes parce que certaines sont
vraiment championne pour se cacher
et une fois qu'on a déniché toutes les
émotions cachées on peut leur demander
de partir on les remercie pour leur
visite dans leur dis qu'il est temps
pour elle de s'en aller
la respiration est une des clés pour
chasser les indésirables
la respiration est un pouvoir magique
qui peut nous aider à gérer tous nos
états interne et la bonne nouvelle c'est
que nous avons tous ce pouvoir il est
même livré à la naissance mais le
problème c'est qu'on nous a pas après
nous en servir pourtant le corps lui
l'utilisent en permanence spontanément
imaginez que vous rentrez à la maison un
soir après une grosse journée de travail
vous êtes fatigué il est tard et en
franchissant la porte vous découvrez que
les enfants qui ne sont pas douché court
partout dans la maison dans la maison
c'est le bazar le repas n'est pas prêt
et votre ville vous accueille avec un an
fin voilà tu as prévu quelque chose à
manger
ok je sais pas pour vous typique mais
moi dans ce cas mon corps il me fait
souffler parce qu'à ce moment là si je
souffre le pas il ya des chances que je
me met en colère
c'est la magie du soupir ce même soupir
qui se fait un peu plus fort quand vous
êtes vraiment énervé
le corps naturellement nous aident à
chasser les émotions désagréables par le
souffle il nous donne un message et nous
ouvre la voie et à nous d'y répondre en
utilisant ce souffle au maximum on
respire profondément
mais revenons à notre maison des
émotions
une fois que j'ai chassé les fds les
indésirables
grâce à la magie du souffle à la magie
de la respiration mais je dois faire le
grand ménage
le corps garde une trace des blessures
émotionnelles comme la maison garder
trace après une grosse fête
en sophrologie on utilise la relaxation
dynamique
l'objectif étant de libérer les tensions
physiques afin de libérer les tensions
psychique
tiara elle adore la relaxation en
mouvement on passe l'épongé magique on
se sert du suspect super aspirateur on
secoue les tapis
c'est un peu comme blanche neige qui
nettoie en chantant et en dansant vous
avez vu comme elle a l'air de se sentir
heureuse comme quoi le ménage ça peut
rendre joyeux
il ya quelques temps lors d'une séance
qui aura m'a dit tu sais benjamin une
encore venu m'embêter aujourd'hui à la
récré ça m'a vraiment mis en colère mais
là j'ai fait comme tu m'as dit j'ai pris
trois grandes respirations et j'ai fait
le volcan de la colère après ça je me
suis senti tout de suite mieux et
benjamin il n'est plus revenu m'embêter
aujourd'hui kiara elle a tous les outils
nécessaires pour accueillir et gérer ce
qui se passe en aile
on éduque nos enfants en permanence à
travers chaque moment chaque geste du
quotidien mais est ce qu on leur apprend
réellement être heureux être bien dans
leurs baskets
le bonheur aussi ça prend et on peut le
faire on leur apprenant à prendre soin
de leurs maisons des émotions chaque
jour en instaurant des petits rituels en
famille par exemple
rentrant de l'école ou pendant le dîner
on prend un temps pour se raconter sa
journée
exprimer ce que l'on a ressenti vérifier
si des émotions sont encore présentes et
faire place nette
ça leur permettra d'accéder un bien être
physique émotionnelle et mentale à faire
grandir confiance et estime de soi
améliorer leurs relations aux autres à
l'environnement à la collectivité pour
les aider à avancer pour les aider à
grandir en conscience et à être heureux
merci
[Applaudissements]